they don't want to do anything to
regulate again I am fine with legalizing
these things as long as we regulate it
as long as we find the right balance to
keep everyone safe keep everyone as
happy as they can be so we can see these
cities Thrive but these cities are not
thriving okay San Francisco is
terrifying and I it's hilarious to me
because the business Community there
wants to put lipstick on a pig they want
to put out this $4 million ad campaign
pretending as though everything in San
Francisco is all hunky dory it's not
hunky dory San Francisco is a nightmare
yes violent crime went down a little bit
but your car is going to get broken into
okay you're going to get robbed those
are up by the way both of those
categories are up and the smash and
grabs and you left bash grabs in LA
because they decriminalized under
thousand keep going I mean it's just not
it's not right